never make eye contact with anyone while
eating a banana a bird pooped gave a
look in the mirror and think how that
sheep end up in my kitchen really happy
today
avocado is my new fave vegetable you can
tell a man by his ankles
I can promise I am not engaged this I
can promise you I'm only 17 I love green
beads stuck in traffic and need a wee
big time how did I get cake on my
shoulder I haven't even had any cake
lovers pretending to be my dad please
stop thank you people at the last hotel
put my retainer on warm water now I just
have a ball plastic haha
fix am already had three bowls of frosty
still in bed at half to well the real
reason I'm still in bed is cuz all my
boxers are dirty if I stay in bed don't
have to change them [ __ ] girls behind
the hotel please get out the field
there's a huge sign saying snake habitat
it's just not worth it someone's gonna
get hurt are you not reading what I'm
saying
it's a snake habitat turn around just
imagine if KFC was healthy and you could
eat as much as you want
I'm so fat that when I twerk I become a
wrecking ball strangest way I've ever
been woken up when you're in bed
butt-naked and someone's trying to force
open your balcony this is gonna be a
strange day one I'm not pregnant
orange orange
all right baby you light up my world
like nobody else the way you flip your
hair gets me overwhelmed but when you
smile at the ground it ain't hard to
tell you don't know oh oh you don't know
you're beautiful